just about everyone in Hollywood
director actor writer producer we all
grew up playing Dungeons and Dragons
I built a dungeon in the basement of my
house in Beverly Hills and and and
everybody comes over to my house to play
it yep Jose that obsessed with the game
Dungeons and Dragons and while his wife
Sofia Vergara doesn't share his
enthusiasm for medieval role-playing
she's cool having a dungeon in her house
it was supposed to be the wine cellar
and suddenly with like the months
started to happen
he has like these gigantic heads of
dragons hanging from the wall I love
being part of it by like you know
organizing the room giving him food
there cheese crackers the 42 year old
started dabbling with D&D when he was 10
and now Joe is sharing his love of the
fantasy game with kids at Children's
Hospital of Pittsburgh you wanna learn
how to play the game yeah we go the
Pittsburgh native and his brother Nick
donated D&D games and books and spent
several hours teaching the kids how to
play the part of this game it's about
being able to step out of reality for a
little walk so you're gonna stop the
wagon stop the wagon okay get out and
see what happens okay I think it's so
important because it allows the kids to
be kids while they're going through
these medical issues that are forcing
them to not be kids to be grown arms
[Music]